こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
ファミリーマートのパンツ全部集めてき
ました
はい皆さんコンビニに行ったことあります
でしょうかコンビニにはいろんなものが
売っているんですけれども特に目に入る
ものパンコンビニのパンっていろんな種類
あると思いませんか今日ですねここに
ファミリーマートで売っているパンを全
種類集めさせていただきました期間限定の
ものとかもあるしないものもひょっとし
たらあるかもしれませんが一応しっかり
調べて全種類集めましたファミリーマート
限定のパンです全部で94品ありました
[音楽]
多いな本当はね全部のコンビニのパン集め
てみようと思ったんですけどファミリー
マートで机がいっぱいになっちゃったと
いうわけで今回はファミリーマートのパン
を全部食べてこの中のナンバーワンを決め
たいと思いますまあまあジャンルとか
バラバラですよ
甘いパンとかカレーパンみたいなねお惣菜
のパンもありますけれどもみんなナンバー
ワンは1人自分の独断と偏見で俺が一番
おいしいと思ったパンを決めていきたいと
思いますまあ1位だけだとちょっと寂しい
のでまあ5位ぐらい決めれたらいいかな
はい
なぜ生ぬるい企画は本当の目的はそれなん
ですけどももうそれとは別にあの普通に
全部混ぜてみようかなと全部混ぜたらどう
いう味になるのかはもうメインでやらせて
いただきます全部混ぜたら何の味になるか
もわかるしファミマのパンのランキングも
わかると是非楽しんでいってくれよなでは
行こう
じゃあまずは袋のままだと見栄えが悪いの
で1回全部開けていきますまずは上げて
いきます
[音楽]
はい全部のパン開け終わりました
なかなかファミマに売ってるパン全部
開けることないんですけども見てください
皆さん袋から開けると結構見た目が変わり
ましたねあの僕ですね今日何も食べてない
んですよお腹はちゃんとすいてはいるん
ですけど
おそらくこれ全部食べると僕余裕で死に
ます絶対死ぬのでまぁちょっと切りながら
一口サイズにして全部しっかり味見して
ちょっとランキング付けながら全部混ぜて
いきたいと思いますはいというわけで早速
一つずつ食べていきましょう
混ぜるのが一番大事であるんですけども
ランキング気になるよなパンが多すぎて
どれがおいしいかわからない人たくさん
いると思いますその指導者になります私の
ことは今日から死と呼んでくださいまずは
もちっと食感の北海道メロンパン
おいしそうですねメロンパンだけども結構
種類ありますからねちょっとだけいただき
ますね
[音楽]
枝豆みたいになっちゃったいただきます
暫定1ファミマザメロンパンこれが
ファミマのメロンパンの卵ですね売れ筋
人気って書いてあるからもう人気なん
だろうなメロンパンいただきます
[音楽]
思い出したわファミマのメロンパンが
おいしい
イメージあったわほんまこれ
チョコチップメロンパン
よく見ますねこういうのいただきます
チョコチップ好きな人はこっちの方がいい
と思うんですけどいやさっきのファミマザ
メロンパンがうますぎる大きいウインナー
これも人気っぽいね昔からあるイメージ
ありますあとめっちゃ美味しいんだよね
確かいただきます
お惣菜といえばみたいな味ですね部活の前
に食べたいです手巻きソーセージドーナツ
ドーナツなんだドーナツ要素あるかこれ
パンだぞいただきますねカレーパンみたい
な生地がしててお惣菜としてはとても
美味しいですママかなフランクロール
美味しそうだなさっきのケチャップが付い
てるような感じかないただきます
アメリカを感じましたベーコンペッパー
マヨうわ上手そう
爆破的な名前のパンだないただきます
[音楽]
悪い味してんなあ
これは悪い
揚げパンサンドアメリカンドッグ風味新
商品みたいですねなんかねソーセージが
入ってます半分に切って真ん中の部分
いただきます
宮台を感じたあこれ俺好きだわちょっと
硬いからそれが気になりますけど
アメリカンですね本当にうまいもちパン
ミート&チーズ
ミートとチーズを混ぜたら一番うまい
いただき
[音楽]
ますバイバイなんかチーズトリアって
おいしいじゃないですかチーズドリアを
ここに敷き詰めた感じですこれはねたまん
なくないですねなんか
常にファミリーマートにあるイメージあり
ますけどいただきますそんな好きな人は
もうたまんないでしょうね僕はそうでは
ありませんピリ辛明太フランスパンには
珍しく明太子味ですかお手並み拝見
いただきますあ結構ちゃんと聞いてるな辛
さもしっかりやって明太子好きはもう絶対
これ食べた方がいいですねうまい完熟
トマトの濃厚ピザパンこれはトマト味が
強いいただきますあピザーラだピザ味わい
たい人は絶対これ食べてくださいうまい
タルタルフィッシュバーガーいただきます
赤ちゃんのお食事うまい
でもママかな
ギシリコンパンうんこれはなんかファミ
マっぽいねずっとサメ用にあるイメージ
ですいただきますうんパンに
マヨネーズとコーンが入ってます三角ハム
ドーナツタルトのソース入って
るっぽいですね
[音楽]
あこれやべえば
めっちゃうめえこれ
多分タルタルソースがうまいです大きい
粗挽きチョリソーいやまたウインナーあっ
たんか
いただきます
うまい和風照り焼きチキン何これ超うま
そう
めっちゃ照り焼きチキン乗ってるんだけど
いただきます
ようまいベーコンチーズデニッシュ3個
入りでしたデニッシュってなんかすごいね
いただきます
国産小麦のハムチーズマヨネーズ2個入り
でしたこれこれ部活の前に食べたら記憶が
あるないただきます
もう思い出す
最初食べすぎた一口でもね90個食べたら
一口じゃないんですよだいぶお腹が
ちょっときましたけどまだ全然食べれます
一口が小さいのファミマザカレーパン
ファミリーマートのカレーパンですね
なんかねカレーがぎっしり詰まってます
いただきます
これで判断ができないな
カレーパンめっちゃ好きでコンビニの
カレーパンとかマジでうるさいんですよ
一口じゃちょっと判断できないね
うまいやつだ誰にでもおいしいと思われる
ようなカレーの辛さを使ってますね
もうよくわかんなくなってきました
ナマコッペパン卵こういう卵のコッペパン
ねおいしいんですよきっといただきます
是非とも牛乳と食べたいトマト&チーズ
人種ベーコン入りいただきます
[音楽]
軽く流そうとしたけどこれうまいわ止まる
と風味めっちゃ聞いてますねナマコペパン
厚切りハムカツあっついバカでかいハム
ガス入ってましたよこれおいしそうだな
だいぶ薄いけど味は分かるでしょいただき
ますまあまあうまいな他のパンがうますぎ
て偏差値だいぶ高くなってますよ今
美味しいですコロッケ&ミートソース俺が
好きそうな味だコロッケとミートソースに
ハズレはないですからいただきます
[音楽]
胸焼けしてきたうまいです
上のポテトがめっちゃおいしそういただき
ますポテトとの相性がグーナマコペパーに
焼きそばファミマの焼きそばパンどんな味
するんでしょうかもうスライスが薄すぎる
よいただきます
ラー油メンチカツドーナツどういうこと
ラー油メンチカツドーナツどういうこと中
にはメンチカツが詰まってますいただき
ますおおおおおお上手やった
絶妙なラー油がすげーいい奴を出してます
うまいお肉たっぷりメンチカツバーガー
メンチカツバーガーとよくコンビニに売っ
てるイメージいただきます
肉味を感じるピザポテトみたいなパン
ファミリーマート限定で売ってました本当
にピザポテトの味するんかないただきます
ピザポテトだまあまあおいしいホット
サンドハム&チーズこういうシンプルな
パンがおいしかったりするんですよ
いただきますバターチキンカレーのなん中
にバターチキンが入ってましたいただき
ますインドミニミンチカツバーガー3個
入りいただきますマクドナルドハム入り
シオパン3個入りいただきます
食べやすいやつねこれはいいかな北海道産
あずきのつぶあんパンうわーいただきます
いい音楽使われていますミルクの味
シミウマフレンチトーストいただきます
ミルキー
[音楽]
皆さんこれを思ってよりやばいです体が
びっくりするんですね色んなパンが
流れ込んできて
胃袋がマジかと
言いますしっとり柔らかバターロール
いただきます
甘いもちもちくるみパンいただきます
もちもち一口も食感チーズいただきます
ぼちぼちプチメロンデニッシュ4個入り
いただきますメロン売れてんだこれ
しっとり
ケーキチョコケーキとして売れてるのかな
初めて食べますねいただきます
スイーツ
マーガリン入りテーブルロール4個入り
いただきます
半分ぐらいいったのではないでしょうか
多分お惣菜パンみたいなやつはほぼ終わっ
たのでここからはきっとスイーツというか
甘いパンがたくさん出てくると思います
おいしそうですね
頑張って食べていこうと思いますスナック
スティック6本入りグースイートポテト
パイ結構しっかりしてるの1個10個
ぐらいの重さありますいただきます
ホットケーキメープル&マーガリン俺これ
たまに食べるないただきますいつもの味
メープル好きなんですよ個人的にふんわり
もツイートしたミルクシュガーサンド
いただきます
お砂糖がその
甘々しくないいやらしくないレベルの甘さ
で中にミルクも入ってるでしょバチューマ
ですこれツイストドーナツいただきます
ツイストドーナツ
チョコツイストいただきます
美味しい
いちごパッケイうまそういただきます
ハッピー国産リーグのアップルパイ
スティーブジョブズ身についてください
歩きながら食べられるパンなのうまい白い
チョコパン2個入りいただきます
[音楽]
アップルクリームこの曲名でアップル
クリームデニッシュはやばいないただき
ます
チョコパイ4個入りのやつだいただきます
うまい板チョコがマジでうまい
マーガリンレーズンロール4個入り
いただきます朝に食べたい風な料理
カスタードホイップ絶対うまいわもう食う
前からこれうまいわ
[音楽]
たっぷりクリームデニッシュお腹すいてる
時だったらもうたまんなくうまいんだろう
ないただきます今でもうまい
大きな
[音楽]
迷わず食べる
戦国武将の名に恥じるとこだったホイップ
メロンパンいただきます
ホイップメロンパンバターかおる塩パン3
個入りいただきますバター
充電仕組みのミルクチョロッキーいただき
ます
いただきます
バージンロード
トリニティチョコディップスティックジェニッシュ
4個入りいただきますヘクトパスカル
千切れるシュガーマーガリンのパン
この大きさはやばいだろいただきます
レミーポン屋敷
チョコクロワッサンこれ僕よく食べてます
ねいただきます
初めて食べたオールドファッション
ドーナツ
いただきますバナナ餅すごい色してんな
いただきます今の俺は正確な判断ができ
ないので
多分美味しい7フランスパンブルーベリー
2個入りグラデーションが綺麗ですね
ペナルティホイップフレンチトースト
なんかすっごい重いですこのパンツが中に
入ってるのねいただきます
渾身やレモンケーキドーナツ
綺麗ですねいただきますメソポタミア文明
濃厚ミルクフランスパピヨン生スコーン6
個入りいただきます
サイコロステーキチーズケーキデニッシュ
いただきますクイズヘキサゴンホイップ
さんのすごいな見た目が大丈夫か
YouTubeに映せるかギリギリの見た
目してますけどもいただきますあうっま
サクサクのチョコレートが中に詰まってる
感じですね
キャビアホイップツゴロールいただきます
ロングデニッシュデッカーなんていただき
ます
ソフトなチーズクリームパンいただきます
ソフトが逆に辛い美味しいんですけどね
もちっとつぶあんドーナツをうまそう
いただきます
ツイストサンドいただきますグラン
ツーリスモ
焦がしバターのクロワッサンおいしそう
ですねちょっと
待ってくれストロベリーチョコ
[音楽]
ヘルスケアミルクツイスト3本入り
ツイスト多いなありがてー
よしだいぶ少なくなってきたぞー
[拍手]
[音楽]
リングドーナツ8個入り
デニッシュプレー
ピーナッツクリームは
ここ入り壺ミニクリームパン5個入りミニ
チョコクリームはここ
チョコチップ
あなたのコンビニコンビ
はい無事にファミリーマートのパン全種類
食べることができました
よく頑張った自分が偉いいやもう本当に
美味しかったです全部美味しかったって
言いたいんですけどもうすいません後半
ちょっと僕自分自身も何言ってるかよく
わかんなくてあのね本当にその当の暴力
糖分の暴力を受けましたがまあでも
おいしく最後までいただけたかなと思い
ますごちそうさまでしたさあそんな中僕の
独断の偏見でつけたファミリーマートの
パンのランキング発表したいと思います皆
さんはファミマのパンでこれは大好きだっ
てやつありますなんか改めて全部食べたら
本当にねあこれってそんなに美味しかった
んだみたいな発見とか結構あったのでね
ぜひ皆さんいろんなの食べてみてください
では発表させていただきますはいはっきり
とマジで美味しかったなって記憶に残っ
てるの3位まで発表したいと思いますでは
第3位
ふんわりロールカスタード
&ホイップです
[拍手]
これね後半に食べたんですけどもそれでも
美味しかったですシュークリームとかも
ダブル中カスタードと生クリームとか入っ
てるシュークリームとか結構好きで
カスタードのホイップの絶妙なクリームの
バランスが最強に美味しかったなって思い
ますもうクリーム好きスイーツ好きの方は
ぜひ食べてみてくださいパン自身も生地が
すごい柔らかくてすごいそのスイーツ向き
のパン生地を使われてたのかなという気が
しますかなりあの僕刺さりました第3位
でしたおめでとうございます
急に超充実レビューはみたいになってます
けども一応のスイーツとパン好きなんで
割と
喋れると思います感想続いて第2位
ウォッチマンミート&チーズ
[拍手]
僕自身がそのお肉とチーズの組み合わせが
ちょっと悪魔的においしいなって思ってて
それをねすごい味が合うパン生地にのせて
あったなと思いましたミートとチーズ乗せ
たもちもちのパン俺はこれより美味しい
惣菜パンはちょっとなかったかな
軍を抜いて改めてお腹いっぱいの状態でも
食べたいなって思いました第2位ですお
めでとうございます
続きまして第1位なんだと思いますかもう
ね色んなの美味しかったですけども食べた
時の驚き
びっくりしたのはもうこのパンでした第1
位
ファミマ
ザメロンパンです
なんかね色んなメロンパンあったじゃない
ですかファミマの全部食べてみたけど
ファミマザメロンパンのインパクトがもう
忘れられませんあれはねなんかやばい
バター使ってるねもう口に入れた時の
バターの広がりが普通のメロンパンじゃあ
体感できないなんか不思議な感覚があって
個人的にファミマのメロンパンが一番
おいしいって思いました第1位ですお
めでとうございますはいというわけで
ランキング1位23いかがだったでしょう
かもうほんと俺の偏見なので皆さんはもう
皆さんの好きなパンあると思いますけど俺
はこういうランキングだったなって思い
ましたはいぜひ皆さんこの123位食べて
みてはいかがでしょうかさあ続いては
こちら全部のパン一応混ぜておいてみたの
でファミマのパン全部混ぜると何味になる
のかちょっとやってみたいと思います
わかるよ
死んだやばい
救急車いやわかりますよ
惣菜パンとその菓子パンみたいのが混ぜる
のはどうかとその気持ちもわかるけどパン
はパンでしょ全部一緒なんです
混ぜます
[音楽]
ラストスパート
混ざったこれが固まったパンですちょっと
一口食べてみたいと思いますいただきます
オートミール
[音楽]
いやーファミリーマートのパン買いすぎて
結構残っちゃったなぁ
それじゃあ食べられねえなぁ